[Music]
no fewer than 30 batman movies have been
released over the years and some are a
lot better than the others and you might
be surprised at what critics thought
about the ninja turtles crossover this
is every batman movie ever ranked by
rotten tomatoes
coming in dead last place with a 12
rating on rotten tomatoes batman and
robin is the critic's choice for worst
batman movie ever featuring an all-star
cast led by george clooney batman and
robin could easily have been a success
sadly the hackney dialogue and wooden
performances drag things down and then
some
no sign of the snowman
maybe he melted
some actors fare better than others in
the movie uma thurman is fabulous as
poison ivy and arnold schwarzenegger is
clearly committed to his grown worthy
puns despite their best efforts however
batman and robin still falls flat on its
face
behold the steaming pile of bat guano
better known as batman vs superman dawn
of justice which holds a measly 29 score
on rotten tomatoes the main draw with
this movie of course is getting to see
batman and superman knock seven bells
out of each other and the problem here
wasn't that fans didn't want to see
their heroes fight and go toe-to-toe
after all heavy hitter matchups are a
cherished tradition in the world of
superheroes but batman vs superman sends
away all the tension and cultural
commentary that makes gritty takes on
batman work so well while sucking all
the fun out of its headlining match at
the same time talk about a misfire
with a 36 score on rotten tomatoes it's
clear that the animated adaptation of
the killing joke just isn't worth your
time sure it's a lot of fun seeing some
of the most iconic moments from the
comic book brought to life but the rest
of the film simply doesn't measure up
perhaps most notably the batgirl subplot
is totally unnecessary inconsequential
to the plot and detracts from the point
of the original story while there's a
lot of fan debate about whether or not
there should even have been a romance
between batman and batgirl most will
agree that it was handled very poorly in
this movie kevin conroy and mark hamill
are incredible as always of course but
even their vocal talents aren't enough
to fix this broken adaptation
just because you throw a group of famous
actors together doesn't actually mean
you'll end up with a good movie want
proof try justice league that man
particularly suffers in justice league
he's boring arrogant and so painfully
one-dimensional you can't help but
wonder why he's been invited to join the
team at all but batman isn't the only
problem here as the movie is at times
almost unforgivably dull brief moments
of promise emerge alongside some genuine
humor such as aquaman's run-in with the
lasso of truth maybe i'm scared because
i'm meant to
scene in particular recalls joss
whedon's superior project such as the
avengers or buffy the vampire slayer
sadly though this is neither of those
properties this is justice league and it
has earned a frankly generous 39 on
rotten tomatoes
joel schumacher's first batman film
fares only a little better than his
second with batman forever coming in at
40 on rotten tomatoes it's worth
remembering though that just because
this movie is better than batman and
robin does not mean it's actually good
now jim carrey's riddler is genuinely
great like thurman's poison ivy the
character is decadently hammy and
totally at home within the cartoonish
environments of schumacher's bat verse
virtually every other performance
however is either tired or forced chris
o'donnell's overweight earnestness is
quickly just too sweet and nicole
kidman's one note dr chase meridian does
little more than spout meaningless
psychobabble worse still the movie is an
overlong slog insisting upon a fun
aesthetic while not featuring any you
know
fun
the first return to the animation style
of the new batman adventures in nearly
two decades batman and harley quinn is
well to be honest it's pretty bad
holding a 45 on rotten tomatoes this
movie has been deemed rotten for a
reason of course kevin conroy and lauren
lester give incredible as always
performances as batman and nightwing and
seeing harley quinn in her iconic outfit
is pretty grand but even that can't
stomp this feature from being a total
train wreck whether it's just the messy
tone the bad jokes or the gross over
sexualization that does it something is
wrong with batman and harley quinn and
sadly the nostalgia alone won't save
this one in the end whether you love or
hate harley quinn there's no doubt that
this movie offers one of the worst takes
of the character
batman mystery of the batwoman is just
as good as it is bad with a 60 on the
tomato meter this animated series
continuation is a real mixed bag the
good well the mystery behind the
identity of batwoman is pretty
interesting and bruce's struggle to
maintain balance in gotham feels like
classic batman where it all gets a
little iffy is some of bruce's own
characterization which leans
particularly heavily into the playboy
aspect of his personality and then
there's the fact that mystery of the
batwoman just isn't all that special in
fact it feels more like a standard
episode of the new batman adventures
than a standalone picture and while the
plot does get interesting in places it
also drags a bit too long too all in all
it could be worse but it could be better
too
a direct adaptation of the famous batman
and sun story arc by grant morrison son
of batman introduces batman's newest
robin his biological son damian wayne
holding a steady 64 on rotten tomatoes
this one is also something of a mixed
bag while there's an interesting dynamic
to be found between bruce and damian the
plot can feel a bit rushed and even
forced at times while the film's
immediate sequel batman vs robin is very
clearly the better of the two son of
batman lays much of the groundwork
needed to make the second part and the
superb third installment so interesting
it's also true that jason o'mara's
batman takes a little getting used to
here especially if you're a kevin conroy
fan but he'll probably grow on you
before the credits roll
while joaquin phoenix's take on the
character has been praised by critics
and the academy of motion picture arts
and sciences joker only received a 68 on
rotten tomatoes whether you agree with
that rating or not you can probably at
least admit that this was something of
an odd joker story most notably arthur
fleck is portrayed as a surprisingly
pathetic character if you're a batman
fan who loves the joker because he's
witty funny and deadly then joker is not
the movie for you
there's also not much batman related
material here at all other than a few
brief references to gotham's corruption
the involvement of thomas wayne and a
strange interaction between arthur and
the young bruce wayne joker clearly has
a lot going for it but if you went into
this movie expecting the definitive
portrayal of the clown prince of crime
then there's a good chance you came out
feeling disappointed
thanks to a passionate and devoted fan
campaign warner brothers green lit the
completion and release of zack snyder's
original justice league movie and with a
71 rating on the tomato meter many fans
were overjoyed with the results rather
than making the dark knight out to be a
cartoonish caricature zack snyder's
justice league allows batman to shine as
the de facto leader of the justice
league as common sense media put it the
pacing feels like it's telling more of a
complete story and this results in a
more watchable engaging and polished
production if whedon's version of the
film turned you off the idea of
superhero team-ups give zack snyder's
justice league a chance it might just
put you back on track
tim burton's batman scores a well-earned
72 percent on the tomato meter making it
the first fresh batman movie on the list
tim burton's outsider aesthetic
completely revamped the character
michael keaton's bruce wayne is brooding
and traumatized his eyes beneath the
mask ever soulful as he works to avenge
the deaths of his parents the age of
adam west was ended by this portrayal
kicking off the era of the caped
crusader what really sets burton's
batman apart from the others though is
its killer music danny elfman's
orchestral score would become iconic and
prince's delightful soundtrack ended up
going double platinum batman revitalized
the character gave the world bad dance
and reminded us all to never rub another
man's rhubarb what more could a fan ask
for a wholly different take on the
batman you know and love batman gotham
by gaslight currently holds a 75 on
rotten tomatoes and it's easy to see why
based on the popular elseworld story of
the same name gotham by gaslight is set
in turn of the 20th century gotham and
follows a steampunk batman as he
attempts to end jack the ripper's
killing spree this is certainly a
different gotham than the one you'll be
used to filled with victorian era
architecture costuming and societal
norms and as batman and selena kyle team
up to defeat the mysterious ripper the
movie is given the chance to show off
its beautiful animation well-written
dialogue and fascinating world building
if there's any other crime to note here
it's that gotham by gaslight isn't rated
any higher
many fans have remarked that the arkham
games are some of the best batman
adaptations out there and it's honestly
hard to disagree an interesting addition
to this video game universe is batman
assault on arkham which manages to
concoct a blend between a batman movie
and a suicide squad movie with a 75 on
the tomato meter this one is great for
die hard fans of arkham and task force x
alike set after arkham origins but
before arkham asylum assault on arkham
reunites kevin conrad's batman with troy
baker's joker as well as a host of other
classic gotham characters the premise is
simple yet effective too as task force x
is sent to break into arkham batman
attempts to stomp them and while it may
not be the best animated batman movie
out there assault on arkham does do
wonders for the suicide squad and it's a
heck of a lot better than whatever this
was so that's it
what we some kind of
suicide squad
oh speaking of that suicide squad we're
not really counting that as a batman
movie per se but since bats does appear
in it and to save you from blasting us
in the comments the 2016 suicide squad
has a 26 score on rotten tomatoes there
saved you a comment
originally meant to be a tie-in between
batman begins and the dark knight batman
gotham knight is a collection of six
different animated shorts that each tell
a different batman centered tail with a
75 percent on rotten tomatoes gotham
knight is clearly visually stunning
while most animated features retain the
same animation style throughout gotham
knight takes each story very seriously
switching up the animation style for
each segment each story is just as
compelling as the last two if
anthologies aren't really your thing or
switching between multiple animation
styles might bother you then this will
probably seem like an easy pass in truth
though gotham night is a must-see for
all bat fans out there regardless of
what the tomato meter says
an interactive spiritual sequel to
batman under the red hood batman death
in the family is the only batman film of
its kind giving the audience the same
choice that comic book readers had in
the late 1980s to either save or kill
the second robin aka jason todd with a
75 percent on the tomato meter death in
the family provides the audience with
three different paths robin dies like
the events of under the red hood robin
cheats death where todd becomes a
murderous vigilante similar to hush or
batman saves robin the final option in
which todd adopts the red robin moniker
gives viewers the opportunity to either
take revenge on the joker or honor
batman's dying wishes not to each with
their own respective paths like under
the red hood batman is once again voiced
by bruce greenwood one of the most
underrated batman actors and the joker
is played perfectly by john dimaggio but
sadly jensen ackles doesn't reprise his
role as jason todd here regardless if
you're looking for a unique batman movie
experience unlike any other then check
out batman death in the family
holy first movie batman catapulting off
the success of the boisterous batman tv
show the dynamic duo arrived onto the
big screen in the best way possible adam
west's definitive bat venture batman the
movie lands a 79 fresh score on rotten
tomatoes the movie's attitude towards
superheroes is miles away from today's
serious minded cape and cowl stories of
course but there is still an enormous
amount of fun to be had in this
cartoonish and colorful universe after
all superheroes are flexible creations
designed to change with the times and if
batman can be the armored jerk of batman
vs superman he can certainly be a groovy
1960s swinger too
tim burton's batman returns doesn't just
impress it manages to surpass its
error-defining 1989 predecessor in
almost every way the critics score sits
at 80 percent
deepening and darkening burton's
original neo-noir vision the villains of
batman returns are its greatest strength
the penguin played by a delightfully
disgusting danny devito and catwoman
delivered with manic panache by michelle
pfeiffer our all-star additions to
batman's rogues gallery
mistletoe can be deadly if you eat it
but a kiss
can be even deadlier if you mean it
if anything michael keaton's batman is
the side dish in this glorious feast of
villainy that's not to say he isn't
superb though in batman returns keaton
summons the riveting depth he brought to
the original burton film easily securing
his place as one of the best batman
actors of all time
with an 82 percent score on rotten
tomatoes batman ninja is by far the
strangest of the batman animated movies
after guerrilla grodd accidentally sends
batman and his rogue's gallery back in
time to medieval japan the dark knight
must fight to survive this new landscape
this one definitely gets points for
being one of the most original batman
tales out there as ign puts it dc tried
something new by bringing in visionary
japanese animators to offer a refreshing
take on one of the company's most
beloved characters and the finished
product not only built upon the great
adaptations that have come before but
surpassed them
certified fresh at 84 percent on rotten
tomatoes batman begins follows batman in
his youth as he journeys from shattered
childhood to hardened legendary icon in
this movie he's still searching the
world for answers on a path that will
eventually lead him back to gotham as an
entirely different man he isn't the dark
knight just yet but he's getting there
the film is equal part style emotion and
terror not least thanks to a compelling
turn by killian murphy as the scarecrow
batman begins is exactly what it had to
be in order to pull off the lofty aims
christopher nolan had in mind a decisive
mission statement about batman and the
world he inhabits audiences embraced it
of course kicking off a glorious new age
for the caped crusader
batman mask of the phantasm has a solid
85 fresh rating on rotten tomatoes no
surprise either given that it's a sequel
to the beloved batman the animated
series this story follows batman as he
tracks down a mysterious killer who is
hell-bent on murdering mob bosses in
fact this story marks the debut and
definitive story for the now iconic
villain phantasm between beyond that the
stellar animation powerful score and
twisty plot means that mask of the
phantasm has more than earned its place
as one of the best batman films ever
made
coming in with an 85 on the tomato meter
the batman is the dark knight's most
recent bout on the big screen directed
by matt reeves this gritty detective
crime drama is everything you could ask
for in a batman movie
i'm vengeance
the story finds a fledgling batman
working with detective james gordon to
track down the riddler before he can
plunge gotham into chaos along the way
the dark knight must come to terms with
his own identity as a vigilante and
decide whether or not vengeance is worth
living for robert pattinson's portrayal
of batman is magnificent of course and
the movie also wins points for its
superb villains and incredible visual
palette no wonder fans are desperate for
more
the dark knight rises lands near the top
of the batman heap with an 87
certified fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes this concluding chapter of
christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
is as dark as it is epic following the
masked villain bane as he attempts to
liberate gotham from corporate raiders
like bruce wayne of course he decides
the best way to do this is by blowing
everything up curiously enough this
movie is at its best during its quieter
more contemplative moments talia's
traumatic childhood and subsequent
escape from the pit bruce wayne and
selena kyle's first meeting bruce has
struggled to escape his underground
prison these scenes are a lot less
flashy than some of the bigger set
pieces but they linger on long after the
film ends
based on the classic frank miller origin
story of the same name batman year one
is as direct an adaptation as you could
ask for with an 88 percent on rotten
tomatoes this animated feature follows
batman during his first nights out
patrolling gotham meanwhile a young gcpd
cop named lieutenant jim gordon begins
to learn the truth about the city's
deep-seated corruption like some of the
best batman stories year one strips its
hero down to the bare essentials and
pits him against gotham's seediest
criminal organizations the voice cast is
worthy of particular note in year one
led by gotham star ben mckenzie as
batman and brian cranston as jim gordon
even better the animation and the
narrative in year one do that superb
cast justice and then some
based on the famed batman comic book of
the same name batman hush is an
interesting adaptation of the original
material that forces itself to fit in
the pre-established dc universe animated
original movies universe and it works
pretty well within 88 on rotten tomatoes
hush is certainly more loved than hated
even if it makes some substantial
changes to jeff loeb's original source
material some that work and some that
don't
like the view
it's the only thing you'll catch tonight
as a direct sequel to fan favorite
batman bad blood with jason o'mara
returning to voice the caped crusader
hush is bruce wayne's official return to
the cowl and better establishes the will
they won't day relationship between the
dark knight and catwoman while not as
excellent as the comic book it's based
upon batman hush does its best to
subvert expectations and tell a story
that while it may feel similar is
original to the world it inhabits we've
got to give them points for that
recent years have seen batman and his
world grow darker and darker as creators
strive to make the character more
realistic but the lego batman movie
embraces the dark knight's sillier side
with all its heart does it pull this off
well take a look at its 90 percent
rotten tomato score this isn't just a
good batman movie it's one of the best
theatrical batman movies ever made what
is the password iron man sucks thank you
a cavalcade of characters burst forth
from the movie's animation originating
from inside and outside the bat verse
indeed the lego batman movie could
easily have become overstuffed but
instead the huge cast of characters
turns the film into a raucous
celebration of pop culture far and wide
you're just as likely to find batman on
a kid's pajamas as you are to find him
brooding in the rain and the lego batman
movie knows this better than any other
batman movie
when you think of a late 90s batman
movie featuring mr freeze your mind
probably goes to this
what killed the dinosaurs
thankfully though batman and robin
wasn't the only batflick to pit gotham's
coldest villain against the world's
greatest detective and since batman and
mr freeze sub-zero holds a 92 percent on
rotten tomatoes you can safely assume
that it wasn't nearly the worst either
unlike batman and robin sub-zero really
gets to the heart of mr freeze's bizarre
and tragic story and michael and zara's
portrayal of victor freeze is both
frightening and compelling sub-zero
sometimes gets a bit of a bad rap
compared to batman's other animated
adventures but in truth it's got
everything you could ask for from a
batman film the stakes are high the
action is exciting and the final climax
is outright epic cool party
do you like both the dark knight
detective and bruce lee style 1970s kung
fu movies then batman's soul of the
dragon is the animated motion picture
for you with an amazing cast a vibrant
story and a unique take on the dc
universe soul of the dragon is something
of a love letter to the kind of martial
arts films we hardly see nowadays and it
gets everything right having earned a 93
on rotten tomatoes this film unites
batman with his former peers bronze
tiger richard dragon and lady shiva as
they come together to battle dark forces
unleashed by cobra unlike most batman
films that have some clear-cut closure
soul of the dragon ends with the hopeful
promise that there's more out there
after the credits roll and remind us
that batman is truly one of the most
selfless heroes it's also just a really
fun movie with lots of martial arts
action to keep you entertained for an
hour and a half
with a rotten tomato score of 94
the dark knight ranks as the highest
rated live-action batman movie of all
time how does it accomplish this you
probably already know heath ledger's
phenomenal performance as the joker here
batman is overshadowed by ledger's
iconic oscar-winning turn as the arch
villain who steals the scene every time
he appears
let's put a smile on that face
christopher nolan can also thank maggie
gyllenhaal and aaron eckhart for the
movie's success who both provide
sterling support and managed to pull off
their own stirring emotional arcs and
beneath it all there's bales batman the
stoic foundation to the trilogy faced
with evil the likes of which he's never
seen before it is a grand sort of movie
with huge ambitions elaborate action
sequences and pretentious dialogue the
fact that it pulls this all off with
such poise doesn't just make it great it
makes it the very best there is
after nearly 60 years since their batman
series aired on television batman return
of the caped crusaders saw well the
return of the 1960s incarnation of the
dynamic duo played by adam west and bert
ward while not a live-action romp this
animated movie reunited the actors with
julie newmar as catwoman to fight crime
in gotham city once more with a whopping
94 on the tomato meter return of the
caped crusaders is everything batman
fans have ever dreamed of since the
series ended back in the 60s with an
authentic animation style that does
total justice to the original series and
a cast of stellar vocal talents we're
grateful that these two tv land legends
got back together especially to face off
against their most heinous pose with all
the powers zaps and whams you can ask
for batman return of the caped crusaders
is an animated triumph and a touching
tribute to a bygone era of superhero
television
earning a 100 score on rotten tomatoes
batman the dark knight returns is
probably the best batman two-parter
there ever was based on the frank miller
classic of the same name both parts of
this animated feature feel like they've
been ripped directly from the pages of
the original comic book generally
regarded to be one of the greatest
batman stories ever written it's little
wonder that the dark knight returns
animated adaptation was so well received
unlike the killing joke this one doesn't
take as many liberties with the source
material in particular the fight
sequence between batman and superman is
incredible as is the brawl between
batman and the mutant leader the real
highlight however is the dynamic between
batman and his new robin kerry kelly who
brings a much needed sense of levity and
flair to this story
also earning a 100 on rotten tomatoes is
batman under the red hood retelling the
story of how batman lost his second
robin jason todd this heartbreaking tale
pits batman against his former protege
as the red hood wages war against
gotham's criminals as the body count
racks up batman is forced to decide
whether he'll go along with the red
hood's killing spree or whether he'll
attempt to stomp him if anti-heroes are
your thing then this is the batman movie
for you don't think twice about seeing
under the hood this movie exceeds all
expectations and you could easily argue
that it outshines the comic book on
which it's based more than anything
jensen ackles was born to play jason
todd an anti-hero with an attitude that
gives him more than enough range to work
with if you came for batman you'll stay
for the red hood
with a 100 on rotten tomatoes batman bad
blood is an original story loosely based
on grant morrison's take on batman it
follows the bat family as they attempt
to take down an evil clone of robin
known as the heretic what makes this
film unique is that it stars dick
grayson as the caped crusader in bruce
wayne's absence marking the first time
grayson has been portrayed as batman in
a movie in his review of bad blood isle
street's mike mcgranahan wrote so much
is made of the marvel cinematic universe
but what dc is doing with these animated
features is much more organic if nothing
else though bad blood is tangible proof
that you can tell an exciting and
original batman story without needing to
stick directly to the source material
another production scoring an impressive
100 rating on the tomato meter batman vs
robin is the thrilling precursor to
batman bad blood an installment of the
dc original animated movie verse this
film is primarily an adaptation of the
court of owl's storyline which deals
with a shadowy secret society that has
long kept its talons hooked into gotham
city after a new vigilante named talon
rears his hidden head it becomes clear
that he wants to co-opt robin to his
side and take him on as a protege hey
ain't you the batman's brat
not anymore
the court of owl's story is one of the
best in recent batman history and batman
vs robin does it total justice even if
it shakes up a few details along the way
critic geoffrey lies has suggested that
the movie stands alongside the best
efforts of warner brothers animated and
honestly it's hard to argue otherwise
while not exactly a direct adaptation of
the iconic batman story of the same name
batman the long halloween will entertain
both new and longtime fans as they try
to solve the mystery of the holiday
killer with a 100 on rotten tomatoes
each installment of this feature film
two-parter is as engaging as the last
and contains just about everything we
love about the dark knight speaking of
if the long halloween feels a bit like
nolan's second critically acclaimed
batman feature then you're spot on both
the dark knight and the long halloween
used elements of the same batman story
to construct their iconic crime
narratives and both do it exceptionally
well jensen ackles known best for his
work on supernatural and for voicing
jason todd and batman under the red hood
plays batman here to perfection and is
clearly the right choice for the role
post kevin conroy and jason o'mara
didn't know there was a mashup of batman
and tmnt well if you 90s kids out there
had been holding out for a crossover
between two of your favorite saturday
morning action heroes then look no
further than batman vs teenage mutant
ninja turtles with a tomato meter score
of 100
watching batman robin and batgirl team
up alongside raphael leonardo donatello
and michelangelo is everything we could
ever hope for and just as deliciously
ridiculous as you could imagine ninja
turtles
as razal ghoul and shredder unite to
cleanse gotham the bat family and the
turtles are forced to come together to
defeat all of batman's biggest rogues as
well as the foot clan who are aiding the
villains the tension between the dark
knight and the tmnt is certainly felt at
the beginning but by the film's end
we're holding out hope for a sequel and
wondering why we didn't get this
crossover sooner
the animated sequel to batman return of
the caped crusaders which is itself a
sequel to the original 1960s batman
series batman vs two-face is everything
we could ever hope for from an adam west
batman story naturally this cheese fest
earned itself a 100 on run tomatoes and
that's in large part due to the addition
of william shatner's harvey dent aka two
face adding shatner to the 60s batman
saga is an inspired casting choice and
one that we're almost upset didn't occur
back when the series was airing on
television as west's batman battles for
the soul of shatner's dent it's sad to
reflect on this being west and ward's
final performances as the caped
crusaders thankfully batman vs two face
is an excellent swan song to these 60s
heroes leaving little else to be desired
if you're a fan of a more comedic take
on batman or loved the original 60s
series this one is a must watch for you
with 100 on the tomato meter batman
beyond return of the joker is the
send-off feature film for the beloved
animated series batman beyond as an
elderly bruce wayne and terry mcginnis
deal with the resurrection of the long
thought dead clown prince of crime terry
slowly discovers why all the other
members of the bat family left bruce
over the years fans of the batman beyond
animated series will love this one but
even if you've never seen a single
episode of the cartoon there's still a
lot to love between the movies
compelling flashback sequences to the
final confrontation between terry's
batman and the reborn joker there's
plenty of action and excitement to get
to grips with don't forget though that
there are two versions of this movie out
there you'll need to track down the
original uncut version for the
definitive batman beyond experience
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]